It really was an
extremely chaotic scene.
We could smell the clutches
of semis coming up on us,
we could smell their
brakes getting on them.
We're walking out, I could
hear somebody yelling for help.
So, I sprint up there, found
the subject on the ground.
And there was a lot of blood.
Even now, thinking
back on it, how much
blood was on the ground.
And I knew I would
probably need a tourniquet.
So, grabbed that, ran back,
took the tourniquet out.
So I set it on, placed it.
I was fresh, I moved right
in, got it cinched tight.
And it was really amazing to
see the patient's reaction.
Bleeding control is
one of the easiest
things that we can
teach and probably
one of the most useful.
So this Stop the Bleed campaign
is being pushed nationally
right now because it's in the
forefront of medical education.
And now, it's carried on by the
American College of Surgeons
as a nationwide initiative to
train our non-medical civilians
on these very simple means
of controlling hemorrhage.
So you can have something
from a basic laceration
that your first step would
be to apply pressure.
If it's not compressible
and still bleeding,
pack it with dressings, if
you happen to have them.
If you don't, shirts,
anything that's cloth.
If the bleeding is not
stopped with that pressure
and with that dressing, then
you can apply a tourniquet.
And those are so
easy to use, it just
takes that five
minutes of education
to be able to understand it.
I almost gave up.
I was like, somebody to
my daughter I love her.
That's when I seen
the Border Patrol.
I hope the best.
I hope the best
for you guys, too.
Thank you guys for being--
Oh, absolutely.
I will always have a tourniquet
with me from here on out.
To see how it worked,
I'm a believer.